Donald Trump is again taking a page out
of the authoritarian dictator playbook
by resuscitating the idea of just a
massive military parade down the streets
of Washington DC full of tanks and
military firepower and all sorts of
pseudo patriotic really jingoistic
imagery remember that Donald Trump
wanted this for his inauguration he had
talked about it he was eventually talked
out of having a massive military parade
but it's back again the Washington Post
has the story they report that the
Pentagon and the White House have
actually started working on how to put
this thing together during the year
during 2018
Sarah Huckabee Sanders confirmed that
the story is true it's not fake news
Sarah Huckabee Sanders says it's real
she said quote President Trump is
incredibly supportive of America's great
servicemembers who risk their lives
every day to keep our country safe he
has asked the Department of Defense to
explore a celebration at which all
Americans can show their appreciation
now Washington DC which isn't a state
does have a City Council and the council
tweeted no go on the military parade
yesterday they tweeted quote the DC
government will open on time today DC
Public Schools will open on time today
sadly the giant tank parade is canceled
permanently DC Mayor Muriel Bowser said
yesterday that the idea of the parade is
something Trump would have to pay for
himself if he wants to do it in
Washington DC and there have been no
official requests made yet for this very
very stupid idea military parades are
the political equivalent of a penis size
contest and they're also the equivalent
of those guys who drive just massive
oversized trucks who have absolutely no
work need to have those and I grew up
mostly in western Massachusetts and in
places like Northampton Massachusetts in
Amherst Massachusetts it's mostly like a
hipster left-wing crowd people drive
Honda Accords and Priuses the occasional
outtie hybrid or something like that but
right around those places you had the
hill towns and the more rural areas
where driving trucks was more popular
and there were the guys who would
the point usually young white dudes who
would make it a point to have the
loudest most annoying pickup truck
possible with the lifted suspension and
the loud exhaust all for attention and
this is basically the same thing Trump
is doing here it's idiocy it's part it
fits with his personality really well
it's not at all fiscally conservative
it's really expensive to have a military
parade like this and also with the u.s.
not being an authoritarian dictatorship
yet we don't actually have the budget
for things like massive military parades
yes some people are calling it
unamerican and it really is and we've
had a few of these like after World War
two after the Gulf War yeah I just think
it's idiocy and we don't need it
especially because I think quiet
confidence is better absolutely we're
not Russia we're not China we're not
North Korea we don't have to showcase
our military in this way every winner in
the world knows that we have the
strongest military right even if Donald
Trump was a great president doing an
incredible job hard to imagine I know
this would still be a horrible idea and
I'd be criticizing it and it's also bad
for infrastructure right Trump claims to
care about infrastructure driving tank
after tank over regular roads is
terrible for infrastructure and it does
millions of dollars in damage and the
fact that Trump isn't doing a great job
the fact that he's accomplishing nothing
positive and damaging our reputation
around the world makes the idea of a
massive show of military force in parade
form it's an acutely bad idea yeah and
to be clear I think it's totally fine to
showcase our veterans right I mean the
100th anniversary of Armistice Day is
coming up right so you've got a card on
your calendar yep it's on my calendar
maybe have some World War two vets
Vietnam vets Korean vets but you don't
have to show the weapons right just just
have the people out there that's enough
if you said to me listen David I want to
combine Trump and the military and spend
some money how would we do it what's the
best way to do I'd say well let's send
Trump to visit troops around the world
in combat zones not a military parade
Obama did this many times Obama visited
troops in combat zones
what about Trump doing that if you're
looking to spend some money in support
of the military rather than this
absolutely bogus jingoistic parade where
you'll just destroy roads and tie up
traffic it's just discussed are you
raining on his parade I'm ray I'm
literally raining on his parade
absolutely the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad